if you want to do big things in life you
have to follow this thing I call the law
33 percent talk is cheap action is what
matters
people marry a lot of oil market a lot
and I hear it every day I think what the
power of now means is just not thinking
about the future not thinking about the
past kind of like these horses need
motivation
he's Tai Lopez and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume five
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one know what motivates you you spent
two years living with the Amish the
Amish yeah how did you wind up moving
from two years of the Amish to you know
multi-million dollars here 500 acres
over in Virginia and yeah if people off
would say they're like cuz I did a video
2014-2015 with I had bought a
Lamborghini and I posted it and it ended
up I think the total views there's a few
versions of it is six hundred million
views on YouTube it's one most viewed
things besides music videos right so
people are like hatch end up from no
electricity living like that for two
years to Beverly Hills and I'm like I
have no idea actually but life is leads
you down a path that you don't always
understand except in hindsight so I
guess in hindsight I'm motivated by
adventure one of the things a mentor
taught me is this thing that I call the
four M's
a lot of people procrastinate if you
bump into most people I meet I've got
about 13 million social media followers
now so I get thousands of people asking
me questions every day and the most
common theme one of the most common is
how do I overcome procrastination fear
and anxiety my answer is like well you
got to know what motivates you and
different people are motivated in
different ways so the four M's and I've
run this by a lot of scientists most of
them think I'm on the right track one of
them just he thinks I'm missing an M but
the first M is material things might
slash money the second one is mating
slash romance the third one is momentum
slash freedom and and the fourth one is
mastery slash status if you look at any
person that you know and you break down
why do they do what they do it's one of
those four rule number two catch trends
my second mentor Allen nation who just
died recently rest in peace he changed
my life
he was my first mentor Joel Salatin's
mentor mentor introduced me to his
mentor put me on an accelerated path and
the first thing he told me
ty if you say an idea of yours and your
next-door neighbor likes it it's too
late it's too late to make money with
that once it's accepted by the masses
it's no longer a new trend and the only
people making money from it are the
people who got in early you gotta learn
to get in early if you're cynical if
you're stubborn if you're slow if you're
set in your ways if you're not adaptable
you're gonna have a hard time doubling
your income you're gonna have a hard
time ever achieving real financial
freedom you can be a slave to the system
you gonna be a slave to the nine-to-five
I remember I won't part of my life going
I wonder if I can ever make a thousand
dollars a month from a non nine-to-five
job then I figure out how to make a
thousand bucks a month I remember making
six figures 10 grand a month and going
man
I make it more money than anyone in my
family's paid you know for the last 50
years maybe longer my dad's from Harlem
his dad my grandfather worked in a
subway didn't have money you know you
don't work in a subway if you got a lot
of money yeah he was a mechanic no
offense to being a mechanic at Subway
I'm just saying he was living paycheck
to paycheck and so as I go through this
and I start thinking like what did Steve
Jobs do of course alan nation was right
Steve Jobs presented the idea of the
personal computer so I think it was
Stanford all these Ivy League professors
who were so smart they laughed them but
you know what
guess who laughed all the way to the
bank Steve Jobs Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg Elon Musk you see you have to
have thick skin that allows you to catch
new trends that allows you to see what
most people don't see so you need to be
you know I'll give you a practical bit
of advice you should be checking Google
Trends every day it's a free service by
Google you literally just google the
phrase Google Trends go look what's
trending around the world
Red Bull the Energy Drink formed by I
think an Austrian guy was now one of the
richest people in the world you know
what he did he traveled the world he
caught trends in Asia they had this
sugary drink that was
well there he brought it to Europe boom
caught a trend and then he put in the
effort there's some other things you
have to do I'm just rolling back I'm
revealing the secrets one by one right
down trend catcher Nike rule number
three living the now that book by
Eckhart Tolle called the power of now
it's interesting I never loved that book
because people use the power of now to
mean they're really it's people have
taken it to mean like meditation and
stuff like that which is fine I'm not
anti meditation but you can't meditate
unless you're the Dalai Lama ten hours a
day it's not really a solution I think
what the power of now means is just not
thinking about the future not thinking
about the past kind of like these horses
these horses is not thinking very far
ahead and horses are pretty happy at
least these ones are doc Duke you happy
Jerry
Jake they're learning their names
actually no but they're just in the
moment so I think it's less about
meditation it's more about doing
activities can be a garden if you live
in a city it can be taking care of
animals dogs rule number four use the
law of 33% I did a TEDx talk and it kind
of went viral and I think the reason was
I told people if you want to do big
things in life
you have to follow this thing I call the
law 33 percent so you spend 33 percent
of your time around people with less
accomplishment with you those are people
maybe you mentor you help right then you
spend 33 percent a time around people
who on your level those become your
friends people you smoke cigars with or
bubble cigars when the last 33% is
what's missing in education in society
that's where you spend 33 percent of
your time around people twenty years
ahead of you
shadowing them and I once in a few years
ago I made a list like everybody that
you think of as great people Albert
Einstein Stephen Hawking Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos Warren Buffett and
I was like differ some of them went to
college but I was like what's a common
read that they all have in it and found
out that Albert Einstein bumped into
this guy I think his name was max
Levinson was a mathematician an older
mathematician every Thursday he would go
to lunch and talk math with this guy
from age 16 on Alexander the Great who
maybe was the greatest conqueror of all
time his dad hired a mentor for him at
age I think 14 to 16 and a pretty good
mentor his name was Aristotle and you
know Warren Buffett got a guy named
Benjamin Graham and as I went through
the list I found in the top 40 people
that you could say have done big things
in our time I think 39 of them attribute
a lot of their success to Mentors
they don't attribute it to oh I took a
social studies class oh I
MRIs things in seventh grade they
attributed as somebody who kind of held
their hand in and and they shadowed
through education processes also if you
want to learn how to have more
confidence check out my 250 for series
it's free the link is in the description
below the reason people aren't patient
is they value other people's opinions
too much so while you're in this
passionate state that's we make
decisions you have to go build
self-confidence rule number five take
action talk is cheap action is what
matters
people the oilmen absorbs a lot and I
hear it every day I got 13 million
social media followers I get thousands
of dfl ty you're gonna hear from me I'm
gonna do the next video uh usually the
more people talk the less they do not
always sometimes people talk and do but
a lot of times people use talking as a
excuse to procrastinate more and more
and more rule number six reinforce good
habits one of my favorite quotes is the
chains of habit are too weak to be felt
until they're too strong to be broken so
anybody heard that before raise your
hand if you heard that Warren Buffett
says it I'm not sure who originally came
up with it but the chains a habit are
too weak to be felt till they're too
strong to be broken so we are all kinds
of Ages here levels of entrepreneurs
and life really I've evolved or tried to
evolve through different phases of being
an entrepreneur whether it be I started
when I was 19 years old
Joel Salatin and I was on his farm and I
said Joel there's this guy that has a a
ranch next to you and Joel said and I
said we could rent he said he'd give us
the land for free to use and Joel said
no we're too busy here on on his farm
500 acre farm I said well I'll take care
of it and he said well you're busy here
working from 5:00 in the morning to 5:00
a knife on this farm and I said yeah but
I'll get a little headlamp you know
those little headlamp things you see
people and I'll do all my work on the
farm then i'll drive over to this other
four it was actually about 45 minutes
away I'll Drive over and take care of
that farm and so I did that for nine
months and then we sold the cows that we
raised and so my first business I made
$12,000 in nine months so made route
when you do the hourly and it didn't
make I didn't do very well but what it
was doing was reinforcing a habit or a
pattern that when you go out and do
something it succeeds and so that's why
I was saying the chains a habit a lot of
people for varying reasons as
entrepreneurs they fail a lot at the
beginning which starts to create habits
of the mind patterns of the mind
expectations of the mind and then they
become like chains that are too hard to
break rule number seven learn the right
things Charlie Munger says don't try to
think out how to have a good life he
says use the principle of inversion try
to think how to have a bad life and then
don't do that because you want to have a
bad life for every hundred dollars you
make save one or two of them and spend
98 and so I grew up you know I was born
to a single mom my dad was actually in
prison when I was born I was born kind
of an inner city in Long Beach and
growing up until I met these mentors I
was just kind of floating around yes
you're in school and but they don't
teach a man about making money but just
has to be the biggest oversight in the
solar system it's like why do you go to
school at the core prac
core value because you have to provide
for yourself and your family for the
next 40 50 years do we equip you with
any skills for that no we did you
calculus which will help you if you
become an engineer which I remember I
was in a class I remember learning in
seventh grade they made me memorize what
the California state bird was Cal I
think it's the California condor if I
remember correctly right but I was
thinking then when I was like 25 I
learned how to invest in real estate and
stock mark and I was thinking I could
have waited on the California state bird
like I feel like you can learn that at
60 and you'll still have an enriched
life but you may want to teach kids
before they're 18 like how to do their
taxes how to invest how to do real
estate how to sign a contract there's
zero of that in school even in college I
hire PhDs that are just morons or
actually don't hire my interview and I'm
thinking get your money back son there's
there's one there's depend on who you
ask there's 1.2 trillion dollars of
recorded debt for college in the United
States and they think if you can't
untracked loans from parents we're
talking two trillion dollars in debt and
people are coming out knowing nothing
common sense is no longer a common you
know and so how does a society survive
that doesn't know how to take care of
themselves it ends up in a government
state that becomes a solution rule
number eight study the outliers when I
began to study both I had five
millionare mentors over a series of
years got dropped out of college I had
no money I was sleeping on a couch
mobile back to the mobile home again no
college degree no future didn't have a
car didn't even have a suit to interview
for a job no qualifications for a
regular mainstream job I spent seven
years on a farm so I only had farm
qualifications I'm at the end of my rope
and then I said wait a sec I'm gonna
start researching because there are a
few people the one out of a hundred
people that pull themselves out of it
what do they do different you
gotta study people that they call
outliers you can't just study
the masses the masses has always been
wrong the masses or you know look at
science gravity Sir Isaac Newton or
Leonardo da Vinci or people that were
ahead of their time Martin Luther King
jr. Gandhi these people are criticized
scorned oftentimes murdered by the
masses the masses are almost always
wrong so I said I forget the masses I'm
gonna look at the one and in a million
or the one in a hundred that pulls it
off rule number nine change your mindset
[Music]
I don't know who made that video and I
don't want to oversimplify the subject
but I'll tell you from somebody who's
been poor and I've been rich that
perception is everything what you
perceived to be impossible you will
never even attempt and it will become
harder and harder what you perceive to
be easy will become easier and easier
and the reason the rich stay richer is
because they've seen someone else to do
it maybe their parents or a mentor and
the reason the poor stay poor is they've
never seen it done so it seems
impossible change your mindset change
your bank account and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is get outdoors you know better
than Lamborghini a real horse got real
horsepower there's more than one
horsepower just like Ferraris the horse
of all goodbye City and that by the
river can you hear it that's the best
sound
[Applause]
right here is where I want to build a
house look at this house site that's the
Appalachian Trail over there now you
never want to build on top of a hill
completely because of the wind the views
are beautiful can hardly walk now I've
got a special bonus kit from Ty on how
to take risks that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the mindset shift that you need
to make this week number two who are
three outliers that you can study today
and number three how can you reinforce
the good habits that you want to build
so I went through the regular kind of
education system but then I was 18
graduated high school was gonna go to
college and a guy called me up guy named
Joel Salatin and said do you want me to
mentor you I'm doing a six-month
apprenticeship he had a farm in Virginia
it's like completely different cuz I
grew up I was born in LA and I said I
wonder if I should do this my stepdad I
had kind of a rough childhood but one
piece of good advice my stepdad I did he
said you can always go to college later
you might not get a chance to do a
mentorship with this guy
and so I went up there for six months I
lived in a little cabin in his backyard
it's a 500 acre farm I worked 12 hours a
day for I ended up being there for about
two years and it changed my life because
instead of being in a system where I had
lectures and professors talking to me
and you're partying and all that I was
20 or 16 hours a day with somebody 20
years ahead
me
if you want more tight Lopez check out
the first top 10 rules I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
life is very short I see people going oh
I'm 22 I only have you know I have all
the world in front of it you don't first
of all tomorrow's not guaranteed